welcome to this video bat Minton okay
from Finland oh no wanted to play d 6
okay hmm so I have to somehow play the
hippopotamus did what but ok let's try
to kind of play the hippopotamus it's
not that bad it is kind of bad
especially against this broad c4d fire
deform efore d4c for him against a 4d
for a knight on c3 em I'm kind of almost
believing in this opening but here hmm
yeah I can go ahead 5m okay so this
should be that bad probably f takes a c5
so not a big deal and here at least I
get a good Bishop on b7 you can trade it
here with the bishop f3 it's maybe not a
bad idea tell me I really have no big
alternative here night to see five looks
really ugly he will just take a night a
form
maybe this one for up to eight
queen f2h for this kind of maneuver is
probably quite good for wide
yeah that's what you get for the
hippopotamus well I really didn't want
to play it he six was a complete mouse
slip let's get the Queen should be seven
ok it's just rolling rolling with the
pawns
I might have no idea form okay let's get
straight stuff
hmm
check aim
just trying to close the position
56 he was taking I didn't expect that I
thought yeah maybe now maybe his ride I
was always thinking night before is
helping me here but of course i have
many weaknesses so night 26 especially
yeah anyway have to put it on before
it's the only kind of justification for
this structure 96 and I by Bishop EF
okay and rock the six also coming
yeah I have to maybe come to a taxi for
a membership on g7 and night oliveria
they're really just holding the fort but
they're not doing anything active soma
takings you for I'm not quite sure what
you should do feel there you can just
just protect it down this kind of move
roop ca8 I don't know maybe maybe this
covering covering the e porn maybe I can
play 97 after all
Rupert e6 second still takes you form
this one okay 97 he can go rook 26 again
and she threatening it now really for
real
night see to again look 26
okay I have to do something drastic here
with normal moves I'm just losing this I
am probably probably a far worse here as
well as I just want to muddy the water
and 96 come on 96 I was only a spective
Bishop takes be six but this is yeah of
course this move was ok but how can I
not not see this here this is really
useless him so anyway some something
good something to get get some play here
Quinn therefore queen dee wonna that's
not really a threat even I can go here
though then I take the form
hmm I mean okay I'm losing objectively
speaking but it was it was worse really
it was worse before is giving me quite
some some hopes here hmm that's so clear
actually I've got one point for the
exchange and this is checked so kind of
kind of a tricky situation all right if
I'm 9292 coming I is got a king after
some
nike 3
time warning okay if to have to have to
blame
this way ever to get this is I've can
always take c7 SD for hangs so this
wasn't such a big deal check
yeah I'm chopping the rupiah Wow check
wasn't quite expecting to win this game
after i blundered this check white
forfeit on time Wow yeah somehow I got
got back into it he was giving me quite
some was quite some some help yeah I was
somehow only thinking about Bishop cakes
b6 I don't know why when he took their I
simply ignored 96 and it's even not that
clear here surprisingly this is this is
really not so clear this or this
computer is only giving white a slight
advantage how to figure out this kind of
technical thing I mean yeah I'm lost but
but somehow I mean this is after this
I'm definitely back in the game here
this is very tricky to play check
probably already quite okay go in g 4 is
equal that the at least the initial
evaluation and here we're just playing
for our four tricks yeah c7 i was hoping
for exactly that so that i can rid o
gain good kindred get rid of the porn
193 i would have one already
okay what with 20 seconds and here i
just saw that this is a win now with the
trap druke and went for it yeah kind of
funny oh yeah well the whole game was a
little bit happening due to this it is
this mouse look I wanted to play d6 of
course and the epidermis is really not a
great idea against this kind of if white
is still able to play this broad Center
this kind of this Kings Indian Center
let's say with e4 did this thing the
hippo is not really a great idea it's a
very passive position you can play the
opotamus quite confidently if if
something like that has already happened
like this then you can can do this kind
of thing especially if why does Castle
showed him he's doing something like
that this is really just just okay for
blankets you can do this kind of setup
and then sometimes play see 5 or g5 it's
me nothing that i love but you can do we
can do that you can play that okay well
thanks for watching